So getting back to how chemists can
have some control over this problem.
A lot of it does boil down
to the laws of nature.
So when you're going to carry
out, uh, a chemical reaction,
you have to be thinking about the
thermodynamics and the kinetics.
So you're starting out a chemical
reaction with raw materials that have some
intrinsic energy and then you're
converting them to products that have some
intrinsic energy.
Um,
the difference between the starting and
final products is that there are many
dynamics, uh, oftentimes though
that to get the reaction to go,
you have to go through this
unstable transition state.
So you have to provide extra
energy to get through that,
that difficult state to the final product.
So you may be having to apply quite a
lot of energy to get the reaction to go.
And this gets into why the
catalyst are important.
I think just looking
at the midterm results,
people understood what
catalysts do pretty well.
But that's basically
to try and bring this,
this hump down lower to where
the thermodynamic barrier
is so that you can use
the minimum amount of energy possible
to get your reaction to go forward.
So this is one of the major tools
that you'd have at your disposal to
intrinsically lower the amount of
energy that might be required to make a
chemical product or make
a process go forward.
So a catalyst design gives
you a huge amount of power.
So at this point I'll try and transition
into how energy is affected or how
energy accumulates across the product
lifecycle. So I was just using a,
a sort of a lunch container,
like you might get from one of the
trucks down there, 10 grams of styrofoam
if we go through different
stages of the process.
So the raw materials and manufacturing
polystyrene is coming from styrene and
styrene is made from ethyl benzene
that's made from a benzine plus f Iin.
The benzene comes directly
from a crude oil fraction.
The ethene comes from a natural gas
fraction that contains these other
components.
And so the energy that's embedded in this
final product is basically the sum of
all the energy that was used
to make these, you know,
to extract the raw materials and then
go through these very basic refining
processes.
And so even something that's pretty
low on the chemical food chain,
the polystyrene has gone through
of really pretty extensive,
uh,
a set of technologies here.
So there's all kinds of
pumping distillation and
compression and purification
steps and thinking about what,
what is intrinsic about this and the
molecule and what is just technological.
So the intrinsic factors are
you can't get around, you know,
the number of carbon atoms that are being
incorporated into this, this product.
That's something that's absolute,
um,
the heat capacity of water. So if you have
anything to do with, with steam or, um,
you know,
waterproof purification,
if your heating and cooling water
or you can't get around that,
that fundamental value,
if there are any separations,
if things are having to be
separated into oil, water phases,
that can't really be changed.
And then dealing with the
boiling points in vapor pressure.
So separating out some of these compounds.
So those are the intrinsic factors.
And so if you're, you know, if
you have a choice of getting,
say ethene from dif or
ethylene from different sources
that these are the things
you would consider. So, uh,
if ethylene has to be separated from
one set of chemicals or another set of
chemicals, you can look at some of
these factors and boiling points,
vapor pressures,
and that will tell you intrinsically
whether one process might be more fruitful
than another.
Then the manufacturing itself. So,
uh, when you produce the polystyrene,
you get these little things,
I think they call them nurdles and uh,
you have to basically expand them
into something that has shaped.
So they use either
[inaudible] or hfcs that's,
that's similar to the CFCs we
talked about earlier in the class,
but they have more hydrogen in them
instead of chlorine. And again,
so that some of the intrinsic properties
you'd have to think about here are, uh,
what are the,
the polymer properties of polystyrene.
It's going to have some certain
temperature where it turns from a glassy
material into a melt material.
That's something that's
entirely physical and chemical.
And then the blowing agent itself like it,
you know,
at what temperature is it a gas? Um,
how compatible is it with this material?
Those are the intrinsic materials.
As we go along here, I've,
I've started adding up some of the energy
that's embedded and just this 10 grams
container. So, uh,
so far we're up to something like
what does that, a million, yeah.
1 million joules.
So when negligible and most of that so
far is embedded in the actual synthesis
of the raw material.
Yeah.
And then, uh, transportation.
So you've made this product,
but say it's at a factory
in Louisiana somewhere.
It's got to get up to new haven that
you're either going to put it on a barge,
go on a train, it's going to
be on a truck somewhere. Uh,
some of the intrinsic properties here.
I mean,
there's a lot of circumstantial things
about how far you're taking it and so on,
but, uh, you know, fuel,
energy and densities, which
one of these things you choose,
which fuel you're using definitely is
going to be affecting the overall energy
consumption. And so we're
adding to the bar here. Uh,
transportation is
increasing the energy load,
the use phase.
I mean you could argue whether you
really do anything with the Styrofoam.
Some people might throw it away.
Uh,
maybe rinse it if you're going to put it
in the recycling bin. So if you wash it,
if you were to wash it for a few
seconds with hot water in the sink, uh,
you're having to worry about how much
energy is used because of the heat
capacity of water.
So we add another little bar there
and then finally, end of life. Uh,
something like polystyrene
really only has two options.
You can incinerate it and get some
energy back or you can landfill it and
depending on which one of these you pick,
you could have some energy recovery
because Styrofoam is hydrocarbon.
It's good fuel. Or You could
actually have energy costs. So, uh,
running the landfill is very energy
intensive. You have to maintain it.
So I was being generous here,
so I added a negative bar so you can get
a little bit of energy back at the end
of you incinerate.
But just adding everything up.
So in total,
just using,
producing and using one of these little
styrofoam containers is about a mega
joule of energy.
Uh,
just trying to convert that into
something easier to think about.
That's like running a light bulb
for 24 hours essentially. So
all these products are going to have
the energy embedded across all these
lifecycle stages.
And so I,
I think I've basically covered this,
but the design implications
are that as a chemist,
if you're going to be building up a
very complex structure from simple raw
materials,
you have to be aware of the different
purification and separation steps.
And sometimes as you go
through the literature, that
may not all be very obvious.
They may be starting with a raw
material that's already pretty complex,
but you can,
like I said,
you can kind of follow it back even if
they don't have this in a certain paper
or publication, you can try
and figure out, uh, what it's,
what it's family tree is.
Did it come from a petroleum
in the very beginning?
Did it come from coal to
come from natural gas?
And it should be pretty
simple to trace that back.
Okay.
And I think the final point that needs
to be made is that you can always think
about the function as well.
And this doesn't have to be polystyrene
lunch containers. It could be fragrances,
it can be, um, a dye or whatever it,
if you think about like what the
function of that molecule is, it,
it's not necessarily like in the
case of the Styrofoam container,
there's no reason that your lunch
container has to be made out of styrene,
Benzine and ethylene.
That's not the function of it is to
be made out of a certain chemical.
It's to provide structure and rigidity
and hold your food for, I dunno,
20 minutes and the same for a fragrance.
You know, the fragrance doesn't,
it's not a requirement that it has to
come from a petroleum fraction. Right?
People don't buy their
fragrance because of, you know,
it came from natural gas or petroleum
at the beginning. So they're there.
I think this gives you some freedom
to think about alternatives that, uh,
you don't always have to be looking for
efficiencies in this particular system.
You can try and think a
little bit more outside.